c'est un parterre qui composaient à la
fois d'enseignants mais aussi
d'éducateur au sens large entre
s'adresse en fait à toute la communauté
éducative
donc on va voir aussi bien des
enseignants que des cpe des assistants
d'éducation que des gens qui travaillent
dans ce qu'on appelle le périscolaire
que des gens qui travaillent dans
l'associatif
donc là on a vraiment un panel un panel
extrêmement large de personnes qui
interviennent auprès de auprès des
jeunes
nous notre objectif est d'ailleurs c'est
dans l'intitulé de la formation c'est
des pistes pour agir
donc on est là surtout pour leur fournir
pour les outiller pour leur donner une
méthodologie c'est-à-dire leur présenter
des sites sur lesquels ils vont pouvoir
trouver des ressources qui vont pouvoir
eux mêmes utilisés dans leurs actions
donc vous c'est vraiment cette démarche
là se dire que on a une thématique et
prénom prégnante en ce moment qui est
forte mais une volonté de chacun de
s'investir là dessus mais pas forcément
les bons outils ou une méconnaissance
donc nous on est vraiment là dessus pour
leur faire découvrir manipuler utiliser
ces outils là donc ça oui il ya toujours
un besoin d'outils agent c'est que le
côté pratique sur la théorie en général
il ya déjà eu des formations des choses
qui existent mais sur cet aspect outils
les outillages ressources là c'est là
qu'on vient on vient
les équiper
ça je pense que c'est parce que
effectivement au sein de la société sens
large qu'il ya une volonté de travailler
sur ces thématiques oui il ya peut-être
quelques années peut-être qu'il y aurait
eu moins de monde ou moins de moins de
ressources disponibles sur ces
thématiques clairement il ya aussi un
effet un effet général sur sur
l'existence ou pas de ces de ces
formations